will smith i love you g.i jane two can't
wait to see it all right
[Applause]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack out of
your [ __ ] me
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out
i'm going to okay
and some of um
the things that he's been through you
know with his marriage and that do you
think he could have benefited from the
from the system the way of of this way
of life we're talking about absolutely
he could have i mean look look at the
absolute
he's become a laughingstock he was the
coolest guy in the world right everyone
loved will smith before his wife
completely destroyed him and wrecked him
it's it's it's really crazy to me
because we live in a world now where you
have to be a real
i want to use the correct language here
you have to be an animal as a man and i
mean you have to be like a real top
shelf top tier man to make sure that you
can get through life in the western
world without either being embarrassed
by a female cheated on by a female to
still enjoy the company of females to
not have anyone try and take you to
court or destroy you like if if you're
the top top one percent like i've done
fine then you can do it right but for
the for the average man in the west
outside of the idea of an islamic
marriage for example there's basically
no hope there's no hope like
what are you going to do what are you
going to pull off it's incredible and
and i know a bunch of guys who who are
christian and they go to the church and
their christian wives cheat on them like
the church ain't going to save you it's
this is what i mean like
there's no there's no faith there's
nothing there
and it's kind of yeah it's incredible
and you like you say you talk about will
smith i think a lot of people can
benefit from the entire islamic
view i think it's i think it's
beneficial to society as a whole and we
look at if you want to look at countries
i'd love to actually do this study maybe
you know better than me but if you were
to look at countries in terms of police
expenditure to crime
i would i would guarantee that the
islamic countries the ones we just
talked about the first world ones are
some of the safest countries on earth
per capita for the amount of money they
spend trying to police crime whereas in
other countries we're just spending
unlimited money trying to stop crime we
can't stop women don't respect men
anymore men don't really want the women
besides for a one-night stand no one's
having children no one's having families
no one's satisfied or fulfilled which is
why they want to take drugs and do
stupid things and degenerate themselves
and everything spirals into the other
right humans need higher purpose
and and this is the thing i'll be
completely honest with you my friend i
was an atheist for a long time
i i really was i was an atheist for a
long time and i i didn't truly really
believe in god until about maybe seven
eight years ago i thought i was a smart
ass and thought i was you know atheist
blah blah blah and then
god starts showing himself to me in many
ways whichever religion he's from but
then i realized that people need
something to believe in all these people
who are
atheists
they believe in climate change and
abortion law and kovid more than anybody
else they have their beliefs they have
their religions liberalism and their
religion is a religion of absolute
degeneracy you know like look at the
things they purport look at how hard
they tried to convince the world that
it's a good idea that we eat the bugs
and and climate change and that people
change gender and all this other garbage
so everyone needs something higher to
believe in and i think that these
i mean i correct me if i'm wrong
islam is not even as old as christianity
right it's not even that old is it
well it goes a little deeper if i can
just take a second and kind of
run it down to you see what we believe
is that you have the first man adam and
he was told to submit his will
to the creator alone without associates
not to worship a stick of stone a bone
or anything in creation so we believe
that islam started with the first man
adam then that concept of submission to
the will of one and only one god not
worshiping your desires not worshiping a
human being
anything in creation was the same way of
life that was preached and teached
with every messenger that god almighty
sent
and
from abraham noah moses you name it all
many of the biblical prophets they all
call their people to worship one and
only one god and to submit their will
like the lord's prayer you hear the
lord's prayer oh our father who in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done we say this is
islam
so just like at that time if abraham was
asked if he ever heard this term human
he was a human but he never heard the
human
that term human
uh but now
if
if he was a human he was same thing if
you there's a verse in the quran where
god almighty is saying abraham abraham
he wasn't a jew or a christian but he
was one who submitted his will to god
almighty that's what a muslim is because
people get that's why
these defining these terms is so
important because you know you're
sitting muslim you think an arab in the
desert you'll think islam it's like some
religion just it's a new religion that
started with muhammad no no we say it
started with the first man adam it
continued with moses abraham jesus peace
be upon him they all call people to
islam to submit your will to the will of
god and they were all muslims they were
all ones who submitted their will to one
and only one god
you know it's it's a simple it's very
simple to understand very very you know
and then when you mention uh god
it goes with the innate nature there's a
beautiful verse in the quran where it's
uh it's 112th chapter where he says
say he is god the one and only the the
unique the eternal he begets not nor is
he begotten meaning that he's not born
of of anyone nor does he die he doesn't
have children a dna of zip code an area
code no
and there's nothing comparable to him
nothing nothing if you you cannot
compare anyone or anything to god this
is the pure monotheism this is what
distinguishes islam for every other ism
is the pure monotheism
so i hope i answered your question so we
say it's not a new religion started with
muhammad it's just the finality he was
just the final messenger and completing
it with the the living miracle that we
have today which is the quran because
jesus at his time to prove he was a
messenger he did certain miracles uh and
but if you were to ask an atheist today
show me those miracles you couldn't show
them
but we believe in them but today anyone
who takes a scientific analytical
approach they will see from the
preservation of the quran to the
prophecies you know to many of the
scientific state there's you know the
the literary miracle of the quran you
know there's just too many things that
it doesn't add up that this would come
from a huma just a human being so it's
not blind faith in islam you take you
use the faculties that god almighty gave
you you look into the quran you look
into the life of prophet muhammad and
then like myself and many you're like
this is not possible this can come from
a human being and then you submit do you
have a lot of christians who who convert
or change do you have that a lot because
you can go and watch you know i got
hundreds i've been doing this since uh
early 2000s we got hundreds and hundreds
of uh programs with people
i have a good friend he's from romania
he's uh
jibril romani gabriel romani uh he's
somebody who was a a christian and he
accepted islam you have tons of tons of
tons of stories of people same thing who
are struggling with with many of the uh
concepts of god that are out there
um and and then they looked into they
looked into all the different different
religions like myself
and they saw that islam just made the
most sense like you're saying the things
that it fixed the problems you know of
society it gave solutions not only on
how to go to the from the smallest
things from how to go to the bathroom to
how to run your home and how to run a
country everything is laid out and it
doesn't make sense that this human being
could have came up with these things you
know yeah it's true it's absolutely it's
absolutely interesting and that's where
the base of my faith comes from my my
respect for it all